hey mein name ist vanessa und ich mache
wieder ein adventskalender heute den
adventskalender von daniela katzenberger
kommt euch diese größe ein bisschen
bekannt vor ja das liegt daran dass es
der gleiche adventskalender ist wie von
sally den habe ich
2018 ausgepackt oder 17 ich 18 viel
spare ich liebe ihn jetzt schon aber er
ist viel zu groß für eine kleinere
wohnung und warum erinnert er uns an den
zell ii adventskalender weil er von der
gleichen marke ist und zwar brandnooz
ich weiß gar nicht was brennt muss für
eine marke ist um ehrlich zu sein was
die so machen am break muss bietet eine
monatliche auswahl an spannender neuem
brandneuen produkte und man kann sie
halt dann testen und ja dann bekommt man
jeden monat eine neue box und die dann
schon mal mit celine adventskalender
gemacht und dieses jahr mit daniela
katzenberger nicht die boxen ich möchte
doch einfach nur nein ich bin ich log in
ist ausverkauft denn ina kaspar adwords
geländers ausverkauf ich habe 44 euro
und 90 für diesen adventskalender
ausgegeben und es hat einen wert von
über 64 euro pro gramm so oft gefragt ob
ich diesen adventskalender auspacke und
ja heute ist der tag gekommen ich packe
ihn aus ich tessin für euro und ich bin
gespannt ob das wie bei sally ist weil
bei sally hat sie ja sinn gemacht da
waren so partikel drin aber halt keine
sally produkte was damals irgendwie dann
doch sinnlos war weil sie ihre eigenen
zelle produkte hatte und man so ein
bisschen erwartet hatte dass man schon
ein verliert wenn scania bekommen wir
schon sehen dass dieser ins kalender
sehr groß das liegt aber daran dass der
hai zu große produkte drin sind ich bin
einfach gespannt also 44 eur 90 ist so
ein mittelpreis wo ich sage okay das
geht noch irgendwie vom kalender kann
man ausgeben sind jetzt keine 70 euro
wie von anderen adventskalendern wir
fangen jetzt einfach an ich bin heute
ich bin ein bisschen ich bin gerade so
ein bisschen durcheinander
mein hirn ist wie schon sein feierabend
ich möchte heute kochen ich habe richtig
was leckeres vorbereitet und
das ist noch so meine letzte aufgabe
vielleicht finde ich ja sogar was gutes
zum kochen dafür ja und wir machen jetzt
einfach mal auf also es werden
lebensmittel seien schätze ich mal und
bevor ich hier wieder den falschen
eindruck erwecke dieses videos nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle zusammen
dieses videos nicht gesponsert und den
vergangen natürlich nummer 1 finde ich
ganz schön fans mit meinen haaren heute
ich habe trockenshampoo rein gemacht
obwohl sie gestern gewaschen habe
resetten zum komischen glanz und jetzt
sind sie so putzig
kein lebensmittelrechts in kona ich
hätte schon lust auf was zuerst color
protect mag eine hamas ich wollte was
essen ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch ist
aber ich kenne die makel nicht dann war
auch klar was sie kostet anscheinend
eine bekannte marke
er denkt daran dass wenn ich etwas nicht
auf mache es wahrscheinlich in die
adventskalender verlosung kommt also
folgt mir auf instagram um die
adventskalender verlosung nichts
verpassen wir werden eigene
adventskalender verpacken und sie an
mich ausschütten
also da gab es keinen informationszettel
dazu dass john frieda shampoo das kenne
ich habe ich eine zeitlang gekauft weil
ich das echt ganz gut fand das kostest
du mit milliliter 50 also ein euro das
ist wirklich nur eine kleine
probepackungen so dass man vergisst 21
cent für das john frieda schambach ja
das passt besser zu das merke ich habe
mir schon gedacht warum sollten dabei
partikel drin sein aber ich wollte ja
nicht feiern lassen und das einfach mal
spontan sehen aber irgendwie auch
einfach gerade hunger türchen nummer
drei ist
ja okay das ist schon wieder irgendwie
cool natürlich nochmal drei ist eine
spezialisierung flasche ich liebe
spezies trinkt sie nicht so oft weil sie
sehr süß ist und jetzt auch mit dem
koffein dass ich es eher sein aber ich
bin nicht so ein fan von diesem virus
wir haben auch ich glaube pepsi mezzo
mix ja also es schmeckt schon okay dass
ich mit lange nicht so gut wie dass ich
drei euro
99er ich sag mal so
man muss hier davon wirklich kaputt
machen dafür okay es gibt nicht nur
champagner der mesmer wohlfühlen
powerfrau weil daniela katzenberger so
eine powerfrau
die discos und schafgarbe schafgarbe
sagt max schaaff gaben kraut und dann
noch hinblättert zitronengras
frauenmantel traums sagt ein euro 99
kostet die packung man bekommt nämlich
immer zu jedem produkt das ich ganz gut
findet so eine anleitung genau september
der ist karl ist genau das ist ganz neu
deswegen finde ich den hin ich habe viel
vertrauen einfach mal auf den auch noch
interessant zu wissen dass da immer das
datum steht das produkt gelauscht
gelöscht wurde sorry türchen nummer fünf
mittlerweile so viele lippen produkte
wie es max lipp 100 bist du eine
natürliche lippenpflege aus honig wachs
ihnen wachse in mango okay für zwei euro
99 könnt ihr euch das ding und das ist
der wechsel nikolaus und wir werden
geschenk mit bitte was zu essen bitte
ich mir was essen essen nein es sieht
aber aus wie es sieht aus wie die tafel
schokolade misst also führt daniela
katzenberger fans kommt man leichter auf
seine kosten es sieht aus wie eine
schokolade hat uns von katrina ok alles
klar also wir haben hier eine patrice
chéreau pelle den schokoladen farben das
ist aber eine schöne palette also mir
gefällt die palette sehr gut sie sehr
winterlich weihnachten nicht eigentlich
perfekte diese jahreszeit schon im
beispiel das zettelchen sagt jetzt neun
euro 99 will die nummer nachschauen 99
guthaben kommt mir das gerade so teuer
für k s ein gutes in vielen farben die
verlose ich aber ich habe so viele
farben ich muss erstmal meine eigenen
piloten lermer natürlichen nummer sieben
ist aber bestimmt irgendwas zum snacken
bitte ich habe lust auf
ich werde jetzt den kalender eigentlich
nur danach ob er was zu essen hatte
davon abgeraten da es nichts zu essen
haben
wir uns bei diesem gruß kalender das ist
einfach aussieht macht etwas was man
sich im supermarkt geholt hat die
schokoladenpudding diesen
schokoladenpudding bekommt man für ein
euro ja und man hat halt so koling es
ist ein pudding also was soll ich dazu
sagen
wir sind ganz sicher
da kommt jetzt da kommt das nicht
passt sondern ist der rutsch oder so ich
verstehe es nicht wer ist definitiv
nicht verrutscht der ist so konzipiert
dass man dass ich aufgeregt
jawohl
ich liebe was kannst du dir aus brot
nehmen kannst du zum backen benutzen und
es ist das original seit
1908 also da kann man viel falsch machen
es wäre ja eine coole idee wenn man
quasi ihre lieblingsprodukte reinmacht
denke mal das ist auch ungefähr so
gedacht leicht seid ihr daniela
katzenberger fan und bis jetzt eher
flauen muss na klar weil daniela eine
pflaume bekommt man für 1 euro 50 im
supermarkt nicht mehr einkaufen kind
muss machen kann denn da ist das erste
meine lieblingszahl das türchen nummer 9
da ist jetzt bestimmt nämlich was
endlich ihr wollt
[Musik]
mit limited edition baut das finde ich
mega cool sagt sie wenn sie schon batman
gehandelt studenten kann ich mit plateau
sie zwar nicht so gut vertragen es
müsste jetzt eine tablette nehmen aber
ich es trotzdem ein prima sahne pulver
vollmilchpulver süß molkenpulver hat ist
laktose bombe als kind habe ich schon
gelten so geliebt weiß nicht warum ich
fand das immer so cool dass das schon so
fertige stücke waren die man nur
gegessen und die hier sind mit lebkuchen
geschmack besser kann man
also aus wenn ihr aus irgend einem grund
zu retten nicht kennt so
dann hat man ein showspiel und das geht
dann in den mund
sie haben es daran die 30 grad sorgen
habe aber das schmeckt
als sie bei der firma studenten arbeitet
lasst uns niemals eine schublade
rausbringen diese limited edition
schulgärten kostet 1 euro und 19
wir haben hier einen riegel tracy
karamell nur show gallob
bluten
das hier ist der nix crunchy karamell
riegel mit karamell stück dem bekommt
man für glatte 1 euro 50 jährige sowie
sein also so sieht er aus
das ist
eine sehr lecker und wohl die schokolade
schmeckt gut aber das ist echt ein
bisschen besser halters original alles
nur meine meinung leute die enorme
vorsichtig eine strawberry straw mit
cola daheim niederknien die körbchen
nicht verlieren beim niederknien die
körbchen nicht verlieren
alkoholfreier cocktail erdbeer kokos
geschmack ist denn überall nicht drin
sondern mit mir in besseren kopf heraus
bringen
kostet zwei euro und schmeckt nach kokos
und erdberg ich ja ne nummer 12 und wir
bei der hälfte angekommen ich rasch
wieder gedrängt
das kann doch jetzt erst letztens raus
jetzt mit 2009 chf wie sonne in der dose
mit dem geschmack himbeere ein euro
bekommt man die fruchtgehalt zehn
prozent typisch capri sonne und es so
und sie ist sprudelt also eine sprudel
capri-sonne brust
warte mal 7,8 gramm zucker das schmeckt
man auf jeden fall ist es sehr süßen
zutaten sind wasser zucker apfelsaft
also kein fan von soli muss die so viel
zucker haben aber ich trinke auch breit
deswegen research ich glaube ich weiß wo
sie hinwollten ich bin jetzt nicht so
krass überzeugt es ist ich möchte aber
nicht so intensiveren geschmack also
wenn man hin der release dann erwartet
man so einen richtigen himbeergeschmack
skaten das ist halt so typisch
capri-sonne halbmann frucht
zweiter halbzeit türchen nummer 13 a
strawberry cheesecake yum yum yum yum
für zwei euro 29 kann der tg bürger
einmalig süß ohne kalorien dem probiere
ich heute abend mal auch seit ich keinen
kaffee mehr so richtig trinke und es
draußen kälter geworden ist habe ich so
viel tee gekauft und auch getrunken also
ich bin dieses jahr so fan aber solche
sorten habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert
ich nehme an die klassischen sachen zum
beispiel roche vanille oder pfefferminz
brennessel so was ich trau mich
irgendwie immer nicht an diesem kuchen
ts ran das ist doch langweilig aber ja
weil es mal von den 14
dies sei auch so was mich ganz so toll
wie zwar mit super chilly christie's ein
euro 99 und diese packung gehört das
sind diese
asiatischen würde ich mal sagen
rangendinger stehen wir ein geröstetes
jasmin reis cracker
[Musik]
wir sind ein bisschen scharf also für
empfindliche leute ist glaub ich sehr
schade aber so merkt man halt eine
schärfe zu
ich glaube die sind auch perfekt für so
ein arzt mehr video
werde jetzt immer zwischendurch einfach
[Musik]
menschen
ist das dass sie von interessant aus
also wir haben hier emails quantität
aprikosen honig seine viele teig blätter
belegt mit aprikosen haferflocken kürbis
und
sonnenblumenkernen von hand gemacht
fruchtige knabberei zu jeder tageszeit
aber butter also sind sie nicht wie hier
bekommt ihr für zwei euro 29 hb schmeckt
kilo teig und blättert das ist wie so
ein blätterteig ball ins tor
[Applaus]
also so eine coole alternative für kekse
und so also vielleicht kennt ihr das
auch schon und 40 war halt nicht
übertrieben aber sehr sehr lecker also
es wahrscheinlich nicht kalorienarm oder
die illuminaten ist hier nicht irgendwie
gesund oder so schmeckt wie ein richtig
leckeres kleines gepäckstück supercopa
klasse hat der wirt gemacht türchen
nummer 16
das geld fliesst aus rein biologischen
zutaten werden sie hergestellt und sind
vegan die mitte und legt geschmack leute
das ist hier echt ein ex übrigens also
hier denkmals litschi und
so hatte ich diesmal die richie
geschmack ist wunderbar er schmeckt
wirklich sehr sehr gut die mieter
auch mir ist die konsistenz nur so ein
bisschen zu sehr wie die stadt was zu
kauen aber wer drauf steht also schlecht
sind sie nicht und für 1 euro 60 könnten
sie deine sein ich bin zufrieden mit
diesen snack angebot hier das ist jetzt
genau mein fall
und deswegen machen wir gleich mal damit
[Musik]
also sie gehen glaube ich schon eher auf
die weiblichen fans bzw die fans die
sich schminken fans doch wenn er die
sich schminken zieht echt cool aus also
das ist ein mascara von sm princess
false lash effect mascara ach so
du kriegst wimpern wie falsche wimpern
bei jedem mascara die beste mascara und
jetzt ganz viele tolle sachen macht
ich brauch war für den oscar als wegen
sehr gut drei euro
29 aber nichts zu snacken also wohl
kritisch betrachtet
kellogg's tresor wie kellogg's tresor
ein snack aber
sind es dann einfach nur die gleichen
nur mich in eine clubs packung verpackt
also die kinos tresoren die snack x oh
ja ich plane keine kellogg's tresor
gesehen sehen sie aus wie die normalen
kellogg's tresor
haben mal hast du denn so leider war
schmeckt so gut voran die haben war man
es nexen geil und landet bei den offen
und ehrlich video weil ich hier ganz
süßigkeiten und snacks zu mir nehme und
limonade
die snacks tresor haben keinen preis
haben dies nicht aus gefunden oder
gekauft wie getriebe oder tresor
64 euro
hier steht die wurden im mai 2020
gelöscht das ist schon ein jahr her so
evis zwischendurch muss man mal seine
helle glänzen
türchen nummer 19
ich wollte gerade schon sagen dass sie
hier sechs reinmachen
aber alkoholfreier sekt
sport lingus ist tatsächlich in new york
so beliebt gewesen also 2019 eingeflogen
sind haben die alle rosé getrunken und
dann nur noch rot rosé im kopf und das
ist hier einer der kein alkohol
alkoholfreier sekt schmeckt auch
tatsächlich sehr gut also kann man echt
mit normalen vergleichen monti schöne
flasche kriegs und für 31 aber ich mache
das jetzt nicht auf ich könnte mir das
mal für einen schönen tag wo ich mir
dann abends ein alkoholfreier sekt
rosé sekt gerne wir sind in unseren
20ern angekommen
ich wusste am anfang nicht was ich von
dem verhalten sollen aber jetzt bin ich
fan libyen planen pop-appeal also wir
haben schütteln raten teilen und
genießen in der pop in köln ist einfach
mehr man kommt es dann so runter und
dann kommt eine bohne rausgesprungen aus
32 verschiedenen geschmacksrichtungen da
sind auch keine ekeligen mit drin für
die ganz normalen das packe ich in die
adventskalender verloren das ist ja viel
zu cool das macht jetzt nicht auf weil
wir wissen alle wie jelly beans
schmecken jelly bean bekommst du für
drei euro 15 hilfen um 8.21
miracoli pesto presto sondern
getrocknete tomaten vegan veganer
geeignet für veganer 30 prozent weniger
fett ohne könnte die concepta es ist wie
pesto nur so ein bisschen frecher so
wird sich und schnell wie ein pesto so
fruchtig und aromatisch wie eine gute
tomatensoße alles ist so ein baby
zwischen pesto und tomatensoße früher
als teenager war miracoli so ein ding da
haben wir uns echt ständig damit nun
denken es war nicht so dass man schnell
miracoli essen weil sonst nichts anderes
gibt nein es war lass ma miracoli essen
dann gab es noch diesen parmesan
obendrauf so eine simple tomatensoße und
gebiet dieses zu ressource kannst du
haben für ein 99 22
juti suite die süße kronen pro jahr das
sind mal wieder solche gummibären in
vegan was ja schon mal gut ist mit
kunsttheorie q10 aloe vera und biotin
also erst einmal wieder hübsch machen
weil irgendwie biotin und haare und haut
ja dazu sage ich jetzt nichts weil ich
nicht da also ja es kann ja sein dass
manche von euch damit gute erfahrungen
haben wenn wir jetzt gut schmecken dann
reicht mk die sind zu schauen kaum
zucker mäßig
[Applaus]
die schmecken mir sehr sehr gut pharma
gibt es keine grenze wie viel man essen
darf oder wie jetzt mein hunger ist weg
und jetzt kommt langsam dieses zuviel
zucker und kirchen 23 beinhaltet also
das muss mir jetzt daniela katzenberger
erklären eine red bull in zuckerfrei
bestimmt weil sie ganz viel red bull
zuckerfrei trinkt ansonsten macht so gar
keinen sinn was ich trinke einen red
bull es passt aber als 23 das türchen
weil man ja jetzt energie braucht für
den letzten
für den weihnachtstag da gibt's können
red bull 1 euro 50 mein gott das ist
okay wir haben sitzt durchgestrichen
lifestyle und jetzt kommt das 24
natürlich an weihnachten ist da
ich hab dir
geschrieben heiligabend noch nicht
weihnachten heiligabend wir machen auch
jetzt dauerhaft rote früchte von nimm2
ja die roten sind immer schon gut merkel
grad ich habe vergessen dass es im
zweier als bonbons ursprünglich gab und
gibt weil wenn ich jetzt nimm zwei kaufe
dann kaufe ich immer die nimm2 soffin
will ich das essen kann es dann so schön
poppt und dann die flüssigkeit heraus
kommen voran dem 2 das ist schon cool da
welche mission mann ist die roten sind
immer die 1 euro 50 egal viel vitamin
und magermilch die nimm2 soft sind aber
vegan deshalb hier nicht bei der 24 auf
wir haben noch die 25 und 26 also leute
ist es der erste weihnachtstag hatte den
heiligabend hinter euch das ist ganz
neue text nicht gerade lernen
durch einen blick hinter die rübe liegt
jetzt da und willst aber scheiße heute
geht's zur oma oder tante und so noch
ein weihnachtsessen die keule von
letzten acht hängt euch noch im hals
aber an geht an einen adventskalender
weil ihr willst daniela katzenberger
lässt euch nicht runter enttäuscht durch
nicht gemacht oder sind
natürlich ein patrice blush um eure fade
fresse wieder leuchten zu lassen hinter
glas farbe kann man nichts sagen drei
euro fünfzig der preis zur erster
weihnachtstag überstanden ihr habt
heiligabend hinter euch ihr seid schon
jetzt gar nicht mehr in
weihnachtsstimmung jetzt noch den
letzten tag durchhalten und ihrem
adventskalender macht ihn auch in voller
vorfreude noch der charta bisher 1000
drei glocken mario singen drei glocken
dritter tag 3 1 18 33 wird ein genuss
pur ist das geil wie kriegt ihr verein
euro 80 bin mir nicht so sicher ob ich
den adventskalender mit nudeln beendet
hätte aber nudel ja soll ich noch was
sagen ich denke
man bekommt quasi produkte für 20 euro
noch mal oben drauf es fühlt sich ein
bisschen an die in den supermarkt zu
gehen aber ist ein geiler kalender ich
hätte vielleicht ein paar produkte noch
ausgetauscht weil sie nicht so ganz mein
fall sind oder weil sie sich wiederholen
oder sogar ich finde ihn gut und ich
heute also
die nudel packung ist wirklich da haben
also dass das schlägt alles raus aber
besser kann man eigentlich nicht haben
es sind alles produkte die man brauche
ich liebe ihn er ist super es ist ein
super mensch kalender ich dachte ich
mache mich drüber lustig hat daniela
katzenberger adventskalender ich würde
mich freuen wenn ich den als
adventskalender hätte weil man es
spannend man weiß nicht was man als
nächstes kriegt das könnte alles drin
sein von shampoo zu klauen marmelade zu
nudeln die neue sind besonders geholt
und der stelle man sie es sagen ja und
ist riesengroß der met gemacht wenn man
daniela katzenberger fan ist umso besser
an verdient die alte sich noch was dabei
also es ist ja super klasse
wenn er nicht schon ausverkauft wäre
würde ich euch empfehlen denen an
irgendwen zu verschenken aber noch
weiter nach oben ich bin sehr zufrieden
preis leistung stimmt absolut und die
produkte sind nette was soll ich noch
sagen gut liegen wir in fragen kommen zu
können wir sehen uns das nächste mal
wieder leute halt die ohren steif und
bernice adventskalender kommt schneller
als ihr adventskalender sagen könnte
meine frisur bereit
so viel haar heute serien h